here to have a conversation. I don't
want to have no debate. Uh, as a Muslim,
we aren't supposed to believe that
anybody's wrong in their religion as
long as they believe in one God. So, I
just want to I want to get that that
boundary of respect. You know what I'm
saying? And that's all.
>> Okay. Hold on. Hold on one second,
brother. Hold on one second.
>> All right.
>> Come on.
All right. So, you're saying that
according to Islam, you're not supposed
to say anybody's wrong.
>> No. Uh,
you like to quote a lot, so I got to be
I got to make sure I say everything
right.
I'm I'm catching on. But basically, uh,
as a Muslim, we are not allowed to pass
judgment. If you are a Christian and you
follow Christianity, we can't tell you
that that is wrong. We are not allowed
to mock that religion. So, when I'm when
I'm up here, it's a conversation. It's
not a debate. You get what I'm saying?
>> You're half right and half wrong. You're
half
>> right. I'm right as far as my religion
goes.
>> That's what I'm saying. In your
religion, you're half right about
>> my religion. Yeah.
>> In in Islam, you're right that you are
not allowed to mock other religions.
You're not allowed to do that.
>> However, you are allowed to judge and
call them call them by their falsehoods.
Matter of fact, you're even allowed to
disrespect them and fight them.
It depends on how extreme you want to
get.
>> But that's those are the parameters that
within your religion you're allowed to
do these things. Like for example, the
the Quran the Quran in chapter 98:6 in
chapter 98:6 it says this about about
disbelievers.
>> It says those who disbelieve among the
people of the book Jews and Christians
>> and the polytheists they'll have their
abode in hellfire. Nothing wrong with
that. But this is the next part. They
are the worst of creatures.
So,
>> so when you read that, you perceive it,
say that one more time. You you perceive
it as being spoken to about Christians
and
>> Christians, Jews, and polytheists, those
who disbelieve in Islam.
>> Okay?
>> So, it calls us the worst of creatures.
Hey, look. I'm not saying that
everything is 100% written the right way
or supposed to be the right way, but I
do know the Quran says we are not
allowed to pass judgment. And it does
say my religion is for me and your
religion is for you. And when we die, we
will be judged in the parameters of the
religion we follow.
>> So then why is it that we're called the
worst of creatures for not
>> believing? I'm giving I'm giving my son
a a bath, too. So, I'm I'm like in
between thing. That's why I said I only
got like two minutes. But
>> Oh, no worries. But look, okay. Well,
I'll say this because I I would love for
us to talk when you're not busy. But
look, just keep look into look into
whether or not Islam is tolerant of
other religions. And what I mean by look
into it, look into it from a non-biased
view. Don't just look at what like the
Muslim preachers will tell you. Look at
it from what others say as well. and
what the Quran is, what what evidence
are they bringing from the Quran and the
Hadith itself. Uh,
>> yeah, go ahead.
>> My bad. I don't mean to cut you off. I
just ain't got a lot of time. So, when
you say that, I could also flip that to
you.
>> As Christians, you know, Christianity
says you are not going to heaven unless
you are saved. Right.
>> Unless you believe in the son of God.
You're right.
>> Exactly. So,
>> but but notice it doesn't call you the
worst of creatures for not believing. It
doesn't do that.
>> No, no, no. But let's let's not let's
not stray away from how Old Testament
Christianity can get a little crazy with
with word play as well.
>> No, it can't. It never calls you the
worst of creatures.
>> It does say it does say a lot of things.
I can't remember a lot of things. Like I
said,
>> there's there's there's nothing the the
the Bible only attacks sin and the
character and the character and fruits
of sin. But when it comes to the people,
evildoers, the wicked, and stuff like
that, it admonishes them, corrects them,
checks them.
>> However, it never shows like it never
says that they're the worst of
creatures. It doesn't like say things
like that. You know, it calls them to
repentance.
>> I told you, you know, I you're right.
The Quran says what it says, but it also
said another part, and I I addressed
that part.
>> So, what So, what part should I go with,
man? Should I pick Should I pick the
part that sounds good?
Let's just No, no, no. I mean, at the
end of the day, bro,
times are different. Things are
different. However something is worded
is is what it is. You just have to align
yourself with what you align with. You
know what I mean?
>> Got it. So, I can pick and choose. Like,
if I if there's parts of the Quran I
don't align with, I could like just
ignore those.
>> I'm not I'm not saying I'm not saying
parts. I'm I'm speaking religion in
general. I mean, if you're going to
follow religion, you have to accept and
own everything that that religion says.
>> Very good. I agree. No, I'm not I'm not
I'm not going to sit here and you know
what I'm saying, oh no, it says this, so
this makes this okay. That's not that's
not what we do. That's what nobody
should do in any religion.
>> But just like you told me I should look
into some things and and you know it
does say this, this, and that
the Bible says we will not get to heaven
unless we are saved.
>> Will never because we don't believe
Jesus died on the cross.
>> Well, that's not that's Well, I mean, as
long if you die and stay a Muslim,
you're right. You're you're bound for
hell. You're condemned. That's what
Jesus says. I'm not saying that there's
there's I'm not saying that
>> I know about I know I was never I was
never saying that teaching that a
disbeliever is going to hell if they
disbelieve is wrong. I never said that
that's wrong. I wasn't that wasn't my
point. My point was
>> you were saying that you're not allowed
in your religion to judge other
religions and say they're wrong and
stuff. I'm saying from your religion
that's false. From your religion it does
that all the time.
Yeah. But again,
I'm I'm speak Oh, yeah. You're right.
Okay. But I'm speaking I don't think you
know what I'm talking about. I'm saying
as far as the Jesus part goes. You said
I I spoke on that and then you told me
to to check something out and I was just
saying like as a Muslim, we believe
we're going to heaven whether we're
saved or not. We don't believe in being
saved because Jesus never died on the
cross in our book.
>> But why do you believe that you're going
to heaven?
I mean, the Quran, the Bible, the Torah,
it's it's a it's a guidance a way
through life to get you to the next
stage of life.
>> Yeah. But the Quran says in and Muhammad
says in the Quran, he says that he
doesn't know what Allah is going to do
with him or with you.
>> So why do you believe that you're going
to heaven when you don't know?
>> He doesn't know what
>> he doesn't know if he's going to heaven
or not from the Quran standpoint.
>> That's perception. So you just you just
revealed your how you perceive that
statement. No, it's it's what he it's
what he says. I'm not
>> No, but we could read the same thing and
get two different perspectives.
>> Okay. So, what is your perspective when
he says, "I don't know what my Lord will
do with me or with you."
>> But to him is his return is is
everyone's return.
>> In the Quran, it tells you, you know,
you have the seven stages of heaven and
all that. And you are granted that if
you live a good life the right way,
being righteous and all that. And as far
as what is going to be done, we don't
know what heaven consists of. We have
small details, but we don't know the
day-to-day life. That's what I
>> But why do you believe you're going when
the Quran doesn't guarantee you that
you're going?
>> It guarantees that we're going.
>> Where?
>> He didn't say that you weren't
guaranteed. It literally says if you
live a righteous life, you are granted
heaven.
>> No, it doesn't.
>> Yes, it does.
>> So, so when So, let me ask you this
then. If that's the case, then why in
the world does Muhammad say that he
doesn't know what Allah is going to do
with him or with you?
>> Because you can't you can't sit here and
say 100% of
>> I'm about to give about
>> Yeah, it's okay. We we could talk again
later, man. I'm live all the time.
Monday, Wednesday, Friday, I'm live.
Monday, Wednesday, Friday, same time.
>> We um I'mma send you a message. We'll
chat off the live if that's better for
you. Well, it'll be better for me.
We we could then
we could we could we could get a private
we could probably hop on a call or
something because I don't I don't do it
in the chat. But if you're willing to
hop on like an Instagram call or
something, we could we could do that.
>> Yeah. Yeah. We'll do that. We'll do
that. I I'll get you stuff.
>> All right. Sounds good, bro.
>> All right, bro. Peace.
>> Man,
man, that baby sounded like that last
Muslim we just had up here.
That baby sound like that that sound
real familiar, man.
Didn't that sound like user we just had
up here? He wasn't just giving user a
bath.
Sound just like him, man. The
resemblance was cany or uncanny. Which
one? Uncanny. I think it's uncanny.
sounded just like that dude, man.
Oh man.
Let's see here.
Uade.
Ubin Kab,
>> how you doing? Uade.
>> Yeah, I'm good. I'm good. Um, I don't
have specific questions for you
specifically. I just wanted to ask, do
you know of any way of how I can get in
contact with um, Sam?
>> When he goes live, ask him. Well, are
you Muslim?
>> Um, kind of half and half.
>> Okay. When he goes live, and he goes
live like almost every day. You know his
channel? Shimonian.
>> Shimonian. Yeah. YouTube. But I don't
know how to
>> I know. I know. I know. So, put in the
comments section, hey guys, um I'm kind
of in and out of Islam right now. I
would really love to speak to Sam
Shimon. Um is there any way I can get
with uh talk to him? And so the
moderators will give you his Skype or he
will give you his Skype if he sees your
comment, but they'll they'll they'll
give you his Skype and that's how you
talk to him. I don't I don't remember
his Skype, but that's how he he'll Okay.
>> Okay. Does he only speak to like Muslims
specifically?
>> No. No. No. He doesn't only speak to
Muslim. He lets uh you know non
Christians on non-believers. He he'll
let you on if you have questions and are
inquiring.
>> He'll just join the live and then say
what was it again?
>> Say like Yeah. So hop in the comments
section if he doesn't already have a
link up that he's letting guest come up.
Um put in the comment section. Let him
know like hey um I'm kind of in between
Islam right now. Um I just wanted to ask
Sam some questions. want to talk to him.
Is there a way I could talk to him? And
uh they'll give you his Skype.
>> All right. Thank you.
>> You're welcome. Have a good day, man.
>> You, too.
>> Oh, somebody uh just dropped his Skype.
If you're still listening, Ubade, if
you're still listening, his Skype is
Benny B ny
underscore
malik m a l i k3.
Benny_malik
3. If you're still here, that's his
Skype. So, you don't even have to do all
that. You can just hit him straight up.
Benny_malik
3.
All right. Do I got any uh Hebrew
Israelites in here?
He can't speak. Can we do it through
typing?
Ain't no debating through typing, guys.
If you can't come on stage,
ain't none of that.
Make sure y'all can come on stage, man.
Can we debate in the comments?
GI warriors,
Ghana.
>> Good evening, man. What's your religion?
I'm Muslim.
>> You're Muslim. A stock full of law.
Okay. Welcome to the panel.
>> All right.
>> So, what do uh what's your thoughts?
What do you want to address?
>> Yes. I want to just discuss about the
Yes. The last one. The Quran confirmed
the Bible.
>> Okay. That's what I want to talk about
>> before we continue. Um, can anybody can
everybody hear him? Because he sounds
kind of low to me. Is it? Can everybody
hear him?
>> Okay.
>> Can you hear me now?
>> Yeah, you might have to speak up. But
you're Yeah, it's very low. Uh, are you
like connected to something?
>> No, I'm not connected to anything.
>> Do you have headphones on or anything?
>> No.
>> Yeah. Do you have headphones on? I'm not
using
>> No, no, no.
>> I'm not using anything.
>> Wow. Sounds like you're talking from a
walkie-talkie.
>> Can you hear me now?
>> No, it's you you just have to speak up.
You're going to have to speak up and but
then uh but it's okay cuz I can hear
you. Go ahead. So, you want to talk
about Quran Conference the Bible?
>> Yes, that is what I want to talk about.
>> Okay. Um
actually what the Quran says he says
about Tawra and in jail with the Zabul
those are the books that the Quran was
sent down
to confirm.
>> Mhm.
>> So based on that
we can't say the Bible is not one of
those books.
What
>> one of them even I'm coming I'm coming
even if the name is changed to Bible
good we still consider it as the what
the Torah I mean the the gospel sorry
that is the in jail. So but what we have
as a problem with the Bible the
presently Bible we have is highly
misinter
misinterpreted or misrepresented.
You understand the Bible the issue we
have with it now that we do not believe
in what we are hearing and you know
reading in the Bible today is because
it's mis represented.
>> So the Bible so the Bible is good it's
just that people misrepresent the Bible.
>> Yes.
>> Okay. So the Bible is intact. It's not
corrupted. It's not changed. People just
deviate from what the Bible actually
says.
>> Not deviation. Not deviate. What I mean
is, you know, there's altered. They have
altered so many things in it. You
understand? There are parts that have
been and there are parts that are okay.
You understand?
>> I got you. Well, give me give me give me
an example of a part that's okay. How do
you know that? Like give me a part that
uh that's that's authentic in the Bible.
Give me an example.
>> Okay. The parts that are not okay.
>> No, no, that is okay.
>> In the book, right?
>> Yes. The parts that are not okay. And
why we are not okay with it is because
they have been removed totally from this
very one you are having.
>> Give me an example. Give me an example
of an authentic of the authentic part.
Give me an example of an authentic part
of the Quran.
>> I mean of the Bible. Sorry.
>> Actually, yes. Actually, the authentic
and the intact one is 80 books.
You understand? Then the current I'm
coming the current one you having here
is 66 book
>> and that's the corrupted one.
>> You understand?
>> So that the the the 14 book that were
removed in the in the Bible right now
are the ones that we want to hear and
you understand listen to and follow to
believe that yes this Bible is complete
but they were not there. So we
>> so so so basically the Ethiopian Bible
>> not the Ethiopian it's not only
Ethiopian because the Catholic have
those 14 books they call it
>> okay so so the cath so the Catholic the
Catholic Orthodox and and Ethiopian
Bibles those are the good Bibles
>> yes those ones they have those books in
their books but none of the I'm coming
let's listen let me tell you none of the
present Christian.
Majority of the present Christian did
not believe in those books.
>> It's not true at all, bro. You're only
you only you're only talking about
Protestant Christianity. You're and and
some Protestant Christianity.
>> Why I'm
hold on Ghana Ghana. I want to I want to
touch on something. So the Catholics,
Ethiopians, and Orthodox Christians,
they have the good Bible. The
Protestants have a corrupted Bible. Is
that right?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. So,
>> since the Ethiopian one second since
since the Ethiopians One second, please.
>> So, because the Ethiopians, the Orthodox
>> and the
um and yes, I know Ethiopians are
Orthodox. I know that. Um, but I'm
talking about a specific area. And the
Catholics, they have the good Bible that
has all the books, nothing missing. And
those are they have the Bibles that we
should follow. And those have the truth
of Jesus's words, Moses's words, all the
prophets, the writings,
they have the truth. Is that right?
>> Yes. That is what I'm saying. Because a
Muslim cannot no listen the the Muslim
cannot believe in the 66 book of the
Bible because he believes it has been
altered and it is not complete. So we
need to hear some verses like you know
>> I got you
>> some I'm coming like
>> Barnabas Barnabas is not in the gospel
of Barnabas is not was never part of any
Bible that's way late. So, so when I
wait just one second,
hold on. So, when I read the Ethiopian
Bible,
>> one second please. So when I read the
Ethiopian Bible and I read Matthew,
Mark, Luke, and John and that Jesus is
the son of God who died for my sins and
was crucif crucified and rose again on
the third day and sits at the right hand
of the power and that God is a triune
trinity consisting of the father, the
son, and the holy spirit. And we're to
be baptized in the singular name of the
father, son, and holy spirit.
That's the truth. That's what God has
really revealed and that is the true
message of Jesus. Is that correct?
No. Yes. In what you mentioned
they have it in those Matthew, Luke,
John, Matthew, Luke and the rest. Now
what tell you is I did not hear you cut
in those places for me in those books
like Edu you understand like
these are the books that I'm giving you.
Are you listening?
>> I love you man.
>> You understand? They along they are
among the 14 books.
>> I don't think you heard me.
>> It's a book. I love you. If you if you
read if you
>> if you read the Jes hold on Ghana, let's
let's get let's get to the nitty-gritty.
Ghana Ghana refer us
>> Ghana Ghana let's get to the
nitty-gritty. Let's get to the core the
core issue. So because
>> yes
>> the Ethiopians for example have the true
message of Jesus that he is the son of
God who died for our sins was crucified
under Pontius Pilate rose again on the
third day sits at the right hand of the
power on high next to the father is one
in essence with the father and the
spirit them together making the trinity
because that's the truth and the eth
Ethiopians have the true message of
Jesus therefore the Quran is false for
saying Jesus is not the son of God. For
saying that Jesus is not God. For saying
Jesus wasn't crucified. Right.
>> No, that was not what what I said.
Listen, I said Ethopia that has it other
Christians like you did not believe in
some of the books they have. Do you as
>> I believe in all I believe in all of the
books of the Ethopian. Why why you
assuming stuff?
>> I'm coming. I'm coming. So how how can
Islam be true if it contradicts what the
Ethiopians have?
>> No. Listen, it did not contradict. What
he says is you as a Christian who is
sitting down now, you don't believe in
book of like
>> does the Quran agree with what the
Ethiopians have? Bro,
>> does the Quran agree with what the hell?
>> Okay. So what the Ethiopians have is
that Jesus is the son of God. Does the
Quran agree with that?
I don't believe if each of you has uh in
their Bible that
>> they literally have that. They have it
in they have Matthew, Mark, Luke, and
John that says Jesus is the divine son
of God. Bro, what are you talking about?
>> I doubt that because I know they didn't
say that.
>> What the the Ethiopian Christians? Are
you kidding me?
>> Not because they are Ethopian Christians
that I believe. I believe in what the
book contain.
>> Yes. They have in their book it says
Jesus is the son of God.
>> Listen listen.
>> You're breaking up.
>> In the book. Why wouldn't they allow it
to be in the book? Let it be intact.
>> Why does the Quran disagree with what
the Ethiopians have in their Bible where
Jesus is the son of God? Why does the
Quran disagree with that?
Jesus did not refer himself to us as a
son of God.
>> That's what he says in the Ethiopian
Bible. He says it in the Ethiopian
Bible.
>> No, no, no. Listen, listen,
listen, listen. Don't capitalize on
Ethiopia. Ethiopia. Ethiopia.
>> Don't Don't capitalize. You brought it
up
>> because I told you. Listen. No, no, no,
no, no, no, no. Listen to me if you
understand me. But I can't. Okay, now
>> inside in the Bible. No, no, don't
worry. Don't worry. Don't worry.
>> Have a good day.
Have a good day. Look, this is recorded.
It's on YouTube, bro.
Go and watch your clip back, man.
Go and watch your clip back, little bro.